we scoured the city for the hottest food
Fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got turf set white-eye tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body I'm Amanda
and I live yoga yoga started many
thousands of years ago but in our
Western mind what we think of as yoga
started more than 1980
Yoga is for all fitness levels even very
burly men can benefit from yoga I've had
professional athletes come in and think
oh no big deal is stretching it's gonna
be so easy it can be very intense for
men especially men with muscles using a
lot of strength and using every muscle
in your body it's not just legs it's not
just arms it's using them all using them
all at the same time
Yoga completely changed my life after I
took my first class I really never
looked back
people don't expect they're gonna get a
good workout with yoga but it is one of
the best workouts this is your at-home
yoga full body workout hey guys I'm here
today with Amanda who is now going to
run me through a yoga full body workouts
not sure what this is gonna consist of
but she's gonna demonstrate I'll show
you right now we're gonna start in a
downward facing dog step your feet back
coming that upside down to me I'll take
your right leg up into the sky step your
right foot to your right thumb spin the
back foot down come into a warrior one
okay exhale open out to a warrior to
flip your palm reverse your warrior and
then take both hands down to the mat
step back to your three legged plank
pose upward facing dog downward facing
dog
jump to the front of your mat all the
way up so do that three times okay each
side you definitely have to walk me
through I will absolutely walk you
through I'm a decent memory but it's yes
that good so so starting in downward
facing dog
reach your right leg up into the sky
bring your right foot to your right
thumb bring it all the way in between
hands and bring your arms up to the sky
warrior one eyes open up arms open hips
warrior to flip your palm reverse your
warrior
reach back strengthen through the right
side of your body and then bring hands
down to the mat step back to a
three-legged plank pose mm-hmm lower
halfway elbows Bend straight back upward
facing dog shoulders roll back chest
slips pull these shoulder blades towards
one are they beautiful downward facing
dog nice reach arms up next I'll bring
the hands to Center move about two more
times right side and left side
gotcha that's good that gets the blood
circuit I feel like ten degrees warmer
all right so to recap the yoga full-body
workout here you're gonna start download
facing dog position
put down arms up in warrior one position
so open up to warrior two
reach back reverse your warrior your
hands down to the mat with right foot
lifted upward facing dog to downward
facing dog jump to the front of the mat
reach your arms up to the sky hands to
heart center and you repeat that three
times and I know it seems like a lot
when I'm explaining this stuff to you or
a man is explaining this stuff to you
but the reality is when you get into it
it flows really nicely it's a great
quick little workout trust me it does a
lot for your body whether you're an
athlete with your body builder you
should incorporate yoga into it it's
really good you have questions as to the
terminology you can actually go to her
website okay and we'll answer those
questions for you make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any other
fighting weight episodes
you